if you look historically you can find
lots of examples of states that just
changed unexpectedly or they threatened
to change and the parties reacted
another thing that people always talk
about with elections is that now we're
in a position where we know that certain
states are basically always gonna be
blue
we're in one right now states are pretty
much close to always be in red you live
in one in Texas although that one's even
getting a little a little iffy these
days but that now we're putting so much
pressure on these few swing states so
Ohio Pennsylvania Florida things like
that do you see a risk in that that then
they do it's almost like an
overcorrection where they pretty much
ignore like if they're Democrats like
well I've got California in the bag
forget California and then I'm gonna
spend all my time focusing on these
three other states
I'm not one who thinks that red states a
red and blue state stay blue I think
that there are periods of time where
there is a stretch and that might happen
but if you look at California as
recently as 1988 you guys voted for
George HW Bush that wasn't that long ago
really and you can look at any if you
look at the whole history of states
voting what you really see are states
that will let me back up I also don't by
then the idea that only swing states
matter safe states are important like
you just said no Democrat wants to go in
the election without California it's
back pocket so what do they do to make
California happy it has to do with the
governance it has to do with the laws
that are I mean California is happy and
blue because it's happy with what
Democrats have been doing an office for
the four years that preceded the
election and when they start to become
unhappy they're gonna let people know
pretty pretty quickly right I don't even
know that they're happy in this state
anymore I think it's just like oh we're
blue were blue that's that's just kind
of how it is in that and the Republicans
here who I've talked to some of them are
just so defeated they're like we're
trying so hard we're watching our state
crumble and high taxes and more homeless
people and more drugs on the streets and
all this stuff but they're just kind of
throwing their hands up like we've just
lost so many times in a row no I always
wonder what would happen if people just
Oded without regard to how they felt
about it for every state like what if
all the Democrats came
Texas did assume that they were going to
lose right came out what if all the
Republicans came out in California
didn't assume they were gonna lose just
just came out just came out happen but
also if you look historically you can
find lots of examples of states that
just changed unexpectedly or they
threatened to change and the parties
reacted at Utah in 2016 was threatening
about third party okay so they were just
unhappy they're ready
yeah and Mike Pence was dispatched to
the state to make things right
because Republican party did not want to
lose its small safe little red state of
Utah in 2000
West Virginia flipped they flipped
because they became really unhappy with
the environmental policies of the
Democratic Party and they swung the
election we all focus on Florida mm-hmm
but without West Virginia there was no
way that george w bush was going to win
that election so a safe small state
flipped and changed everything and you
can you can look through history and you
can see states changing their allegiance
you know back and forth over time so I
tend to say look you know the safe
states matter they just are they made up
their minds earlier in the process based
upon the governance that came before and
swing states are just late to make up
their minds indecisive and but everybody
is important you can't get to 270
without some combination of safe and
swing states
you simply can't get there so you got to
do something to get them on your side so
is there anything you would do with the
way the electoral college is set up to
tweak it to tighten it or anything or do
you feel it you feel it's basically as
perfect a system as we can do in a
country of 320 million some of our
people I I like it I when I first
started this close to 20 years ago
there were small things I would change I
thought well maybe we could automate the
Elector you know so it's not there's no
possibility of elector independence or
maybe we could change the contingent
election process you know where the
president is elected by the house if
nobody can go to majority and I thought
maybe you could tweak it but the more I
study at the more I look the more I
think this is just a really delicate
balance and if you change one thing you
don't know what kind of domino effect
that might have and so I would just
leave everything I think it's and it may
not be perfect
but it's the best we're gonna do in an
imperfect world I steal something
Winston Churchill said sometimes and he
said democracy is the worst form of
government except for all the others
I'd say the electoral college is the
worst possible form presidential
election except for all the others that
have been tried right it's it's the best
we can do in a perfect world and it's
got a lot of benefits so this is a
slight deviation from electoral college
specifically but what do you think of
sort of the state of people believing
that system itself works that the
election process works and is untampered
with and russians and hacking and all of
these things and right just fraud in
general because it seems to me that no
matter what happens in the next election
half the country is gonna claim that it
was illegitimate and we're seeing this
even now I mean just in the last couple
weeks now that Hillary's sort of
reappearing you know she's basically
calling Trump and illegitimate president
because she did win the popular vote as
we talked about so it's like it seems to
me that we that again comes to the
optics part of it where it's like we're
setting up something where half the
country no matter what every four years
is going to think that something illegal
or immoral or awful has happened well
this is what I read observes there's
there's an again there's no such thing
as perfection there always be people
that want to cheat there will always be
people that will look for a way to steal
an election if they can I can't fix that
nobody can fix that the Electoral
College can fix that but what we can do
is we can make it as hard as possible we
could throw up as many hurdles as we
possibly can and if you have a national
popular vote system then what you have
is one centralized national base
database that you know or just voting
system tabulation whatever you just have
to hack one thing okay
you have to and that means by the way
also that you have to be on defense and
every single precinct of the country so
you can be in the bluest blue California
precinct and your if votes are stolen
there you affect everybody or the
reddest red Texas precinct that vote
affects everybody right now we have a
situation where you don't have to be on
defense absolutely everywhere you just
have to be on defense in a few danger
spots which means you can focus all of
your resources there and that's better
also by the way if you're talked about
hacking you
just hacking one national tally your you
have to actually hack multiple tallies
around the country because there are 51
different election systems 50 plus DC
election systems so you'd have to
identify which one would be you know the
most relevant which state's gonna be
close which state could swing this can i
hack it and you have to be able to do
all it have to have all of these things
working for you before you can actually
steal an election is it impossible
probably not I'm not going to claim that
but you again you can make it as hard as
possible and make us that they have to
get through as many hoops as possible
before they can influence you right so
okay so as somebody that obviously you
like states rights and you're trying to
you're trying to set up a system the way
it was originally set to be which is
that you're trying not to give too much
power to the federal government would
you leave the voting mechanisms to the
states or should we have a federal a
federally mandated system of voting
because right now it's like we got
hanging chads in one state we got
electronic voting in another state some
states have receipts after the
electronic voting some states don't and
a zillion other punch cards and a
gajillion different things which that in
and of itself seems really messy I think
one of the most important things that
people don't appreciate or know about
the Electoral College is how important
it is to protect it state's prerogative
just to choose it's to run its own
election choose its own electors and to
be in charge of itself and maybe the
best way to demonstrate that is to show
what would happen on the opposite side
if we did have one national tally well
what that means is a national election
code an actual national bureaucracy you
know a new presidential appointees it's
four to run this whole thing that you've
put in place and so now you've got a
potentially an incumbent president in
charge of his own election because he's
in charge of the federal machinery that
will make it happen but how it is now
every state makes its own decisions some
states will make better decisions than
others some you know those again it's
like the laboratories of democracy kind
of idea they'll see what works what
doesn't work they'll change every but
everybody will be in charge of
themselves and that by itself as a
protection if we want to isolate one
clip next time somebody says to me Dave
why do you think the electoral college
is good can you
me like the the sort of bumper sticker
video that we can use to just push out
to people in a couple minutes like the
cleanest clearest reasoning for the
electoral go I just always say it makes
presidential candidates reach out to a
wide variety of voters given how big and
diverse our country is it's important
the founders thought that 13 States was
too large and too diverse to have
anything else we're so much bigger right
now and so people say it's outdated and
I say the opposite it's more important
now how can we expect such a diverse
country to govern itself if we don't
have this is the only person expected to
represent all of us the only one a there
are senators that represent states you
know or congressmen that represent
districts everybody else represents a
smaller subset of people the president
must elect the most liberal person or
represent the most liberal people in
California and the most conservative
people in you know Mississippi or
something so it's just you got to have a
special system in place for that to make
him or her take into consideration as
many people as possible if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlists all right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell